c'est lors de notre page était ce soir
ça ce parc à la guinguette d'orléans
reste hardin et vous allez voir que la
guinguette d'aujourd'hui n'a rien de
ringard donc foire arnaud moreau oui
tout à fait c'est un lieu très agréable
et bucolique idéal pour finir la semaine
et boire un verre avec modération bien
sûr
nous sommes à la guinguette la sardine
en plein centre ville d'orléans un
endroit très accessible alors toute
l'année là tout un tas d'activités qui
sont proposés on va en parler tout à
l'heure avec notre invité
mais cet après midi il y avait du
théâtre d'improvisation
je vous propose de voir tout de suite ce
reportage réalisé avec jean guéguéniat
et sa nasraoui
[Musique]
après midi un peu spéciale à la
guinguette du théâtre d'improvisation
quatre comédiens doivent réaliser des
sketches avec seulement quelques mots
comme repère la recette fonctionne 80
pas drôle on voit leur réactivité donc
non c'est intéressant
le pis c'est pas facile il faudra chaque
fois s'adapter et devrait rebondir à
chaque fois la leçon et raconter que ce
drame aucune imagination sans douleur
pas mais c'est très intéressant vers
chaque fois donné tout en prêchant le
thème au dernier moment donc c'est quand
même une belle découverte est un beau
jeu dexter c'est intéressant parce que
c'est des choses qu'on voit rarement en
première comme ça donc c'est bien
c'était un cas venu pour la sardine on a
découvert que certaines d'improvisation
séguin on ne va pas directement dans les
salles pour voir cette pratique là ont
des arts de vannes milliards et oui ici
le public découvre le concept il faut
aller le chercher et donc s'adapter
habituellement c'est quand on fait un
match c'est un arbitre qui prépare les
thèmes là on va improviser avec les
thèmes de à du public
c'est de cette façon là qu'on va aller
on va aller les chercher
c'est stimulant cette incertitude c'est
super stimulant où est absolument pas ce
qu'on va faire on a on a des réflexes on
a des habitudes de comédien mais en fait
c'est comme dans la vie de tous les
jours on joue on est des grands enfants
et les meilleurs improvisateurs c'est
les enfants c'est ce qu'ils disent on va
être on dirait qu'on serait le papa et
la maman et que on irait à ses anciens
et et en fait on replonge là dedans
quand on est français
le public de la guinguette et conti ça
tombe bien la compagnie orléanaise
quiproquos recherche de nouveaux membres
pour être ici dans le jeu mais on va
être rude et non même dans mon pays et
je suis et pour parler de la
programmation de la gaillette je suis
avec semelle québec qui s'occupe de la
guinguette la sardine alors merci d'être
avec nous paris nous un petit peu de ce
qu'on peut trouver ici des concerts des
dj q comment ça se passe alors oui une
programmation tout l'été on est ouvert
du mercredi au dimanche avec des
concerts des dj sets
certains soirs et puis de la danse aussi
dimanche
et puis certains dimanches comme
aujourd'hui une nouveauté avec du thème
d'improvisation ça fait cinq ans
maintenant que la guinguette existe à
orléans centre ville quel bilan on peut
tirer les gens s'habituent à cet endroit
non seulement ça bitume et attendre le
retour de la langue est tous les ans
et puis on s'aperçoit que on a de plus
en plus des mondes qui vient en tout cas
quand il fait beau parent devançant le
temps avec nous on est loin c'est ce
qu'on disait dans un journal on est loin
de l'image désuète le peuvent avoir
certaines guette ici il ya des
expérimentations il ya des choses
nouvelles chaque année presque
on essaye en tout cas de changer les
choses est de faire découvrir en tout
cas des nouveaux artistes de la
programmation qu'elle soit éthique qui
en a pour tous les goûts et puis et de
qualité surtout la saison se termine
début septembre
qu'est ce qu'on va voir d'ici là il y
aura des concerts il ya des choses un
peu particulière alors il ya encore des
concerts la semaine prochaine un concert
d'une soirée mariniers il ya des dj sets
on aura aussi le plaisir de recevoir ce
kaiser pour le dernier week-end de
septembre
tiens un groupe d'orléans qui va sortir
son nouveau cd l'a donc son nouvel album
donc on est content car ça et parce que
ce qu'on voit c'est qu'il faut aussi
composer avec un univers local allées
marines et les groupes locaux et ça
c'est quelque chose qui vous tient à
coeur
nos depuis le début on essaye d'avoir et
du local et du national l'international
comme cette année où on a eu des groupes
du canada on a eu des groupes de chine
on a vu des groupes de la réunion
évidemment on garde un pub local alors
malheureusement il ya eu un été un peu
mitigé niveau météo est ce que cela
s'est ressenti sur la fréquentation
pour nous ça se ressent forcément après
on est sur un lieu qui parfait quand il
fait beau et qu'il est moins forcément
quand il ne sait pas on le sait dès le
départ c'est le jeu la saison avait bien
démarré elle finit un peu moins moins
bien en tout cas mais bon il parait que
les erreurs les beaux jours reviennent
donc tenir bien merci ça mail merci
beaucoup et puis donc la guinguette
reviendra comme elle l année prochaine
on rappelle que vous avez jusqu'au 10
septembre assez ça pour jusqu'au 10
septembre pour venir apprécier les
groupes et les concerts ici à la
guinguette dans l'est en plein centre
ville près de la place de loire merci
arnaud